[موسيقى]
ويبدو ان الصين لديها شبكه
فيها حوالي 900
منتجعات التكنولوجيه مدعومه من قبل الدوله
لديهم اسماء مختلفه لهذه المجمعات
والارقام ربما اكثر من 900 الان ولكنها
موجوده فقط
لاستغلال هذه التكنولوجيا على الصعيد
التجاري او حتى لتحويلها الى اسلحه
واستخدام اكي اسلحه وهذا مجمعات
احجامه مختلفه تماما من مباني فيها عده
طوابق او حتى اماكن فيها عدد صغير من
الاشخاص وهنا تاتي عمليه التحويل هذه
التكنولوجيا الى المجال التجاري
[موسيقى]
لا استطيع قراءه المستقبل ولكن ما نعرفه
الى الان هو ان كافولي الخبير الصيني في
ذكاء الصناعي وذكر في كتابه القوى الخارقه
الصناعيه قل بان الشركات الصينيه بها
السمعه في تحويل التكنولوجيا التجاريه من
ضمنها حتى اذا كان الاصطناعي ولكن الصين
لم تكن الرائده في العالم في ابتكار
تكنولوجيا كل هذا صحيح ولا جدل في ذلك
ولكن هنالك ادله في كتابنا ساريكم اياه
وهو القوى الصينيه وذكاء الاصطناعي
وان هذا نموذج بدا يتغير
ومؤتمرات علميه وابحاثه
لمختبراتك صناعي مملكه للدوله او خاصه
الصين تحقق وتقدمها كبيره في مجالات متقدم
ذكاء الاصطناعي لمعالجه المشاكل في هذا
المجال باستخدام الاساليب الابداعيه التي
تتبع
الممارسات الم بها
[موسيقى]